I got good news for everybody from
American Military news 18,000 border
patrol agents support Texas and blast
the Biden Administration a statement
released Thursday by the nbpc which is
the official Union of over 18,000
Customs and Border Protection uh
employees pushed back against the what
the union described as fake news reports
that the border patrol agents would be
arresting Texas National Guardsman at
the border quote Rank and file BP agents
are not going to start arresting Texas
National Guard members for following
their lawful orders that's fake news the
Texas National Guard and rank and file
BP agents work together and respect each
other's jobs period if Texas National
Guard members have lawful orders then
they have to carry out those orders so
this is great uh and I think it shows
the emperor has no close Joe Biden is is
impotent here I don't know that I
believe it completely that I like you
know things are always not what they
seem it may be uh that the Customs and
Border Patrol agents are no no no we're
not going to do any of that stuff we're
they're in lawful orders but behind the
scenes CBP is just saying say this avoid
conflict or the unionist avoid the
conflict but try and keep doing your
job I want to believe I want to be
optimistic Joe Biden says go fight CBP
says we're we're not going to fight over
this TCH National Guard they're in the
right no conflict we move on I think
it's a good thing because as I've said
before the win condition for the left is
a civil war starting not fighting a
Civil War and winning so I want to give
a shout out to the you know what I love
I just these leftists who love putting
my name in their YouTube videos and then
arguing something I've never been in
favor of they're like Tim pool's arguing
about Civil War blah blah blah and I was
like I have literally said your win
condition is starting a Civil War and we
want to avoid at all costs so thank you
and have a nice day but yeah I don't
know what you guys think good news uh
yeah I I know when I was with Carrie
Lake uh at her Senate announcement she
shared letters uh she read one with me
from a guy who was working border patrol
who was like this place is defunct
they're not running this place properly
we need help I shared that one letter in
the last car Lake article I wrote for
scanner um so like people obviously are
going against the administration uh they
have to because they see just so much
fentanyl pouring over that border uh
Terri wasn't there like some big story
where someone died from uh fentel laced
uh pot recently I didn't see it I can't
remember exactly what the story was I
just know that it came up because
someone was asking me about it and like
how does these things happen I'm like it
sounds like they're trying to kill
people by doing it I believe yeah I
believe they are I'm blanking on who it
was but it's a um famous uh celebrity
son yeah the guy from Pawn Stars right
yeah pawn star he said and he blamed he
literally blamed the Border uh yeah
absolutely at car Lake's announcement uh
she filled the stage with parents who
lost children to fentanyl in various
ways whether it was like you know and
bring it back to Prince really quick
people forget Prince was on different
pain meds someone gave him a counterfeit
pill that was Fentanyl and that's what
MC Miller right yes supposedly I'm not
sure if it was fentel with MC Miller or
something else but uh I know if Prince
it was it's it's everywhere it's
prevalent no one's safe not Prince and
not you know the people in these border
towns and the rest of this country Dez
Dickerson who was um a Prince's guitar
player in the revolution he's the guy
that wanted the comicazi headband in
1999 sang some of the song You know the
song well Dez has been a good friend of
mine for over 30 years and he told me
absolutely 100% that that Prince that
was an accident this was not something
that Prince did to himself by oh yeah
this was I believe that and they never
caught the person who gave him the
counterfeit right we know Michael
Jackson was killed by a doctor and he
spent two years in jail but Prince's
whoever gave him the counterfeit drug
that was fentol yeah I never MC Miller
MC Miller was fentol and they put
whoever gave it to him in jail as well
uh it's weird I mean I feel like the
obvious answer is close of the Border
but people have been so averse to it for
so long we're really feeling the
consequence of it now I feel like it's a
an another easy attack Vector for China
yes pot laced with fentanyl yeah and
then a bunch of young people die I mean
there's isn't someone from the Biden
administrating is meeting with a
representative from China this week I'm
pretty sure this happened once before
earlier this year Biden met with uh she
ping in San Francisco I think and they
were like so tell us that you'll stop uh
because a lot of stuff that goes into
fentanyl is is manufactured in China and
shipped to Mexico and comes across the
border and he was like so please tell us
you you'll stop that and they were like
we'll see we'll think about it we'll
work with you like the fact that we
couldn't even get China to commit to
being like okay fine we'll stop shipping
fent all like we're in a weak position
because we made our border weak and by
the way people fly I mean Chinese people
will fly to uh both South America and to
Canada to then Traverse into America
through the Border like we're we're
we're bad on both sides right like the
the US Mexico border has been weak for a
long time and we're seeing the effect of
it now but I think it's also important
to start talking about what's happening
on the northern border where they are
seeing an uh an an a rise in illegal
Crossings and especially during this
time of year it's incredibly dangerous
for both the the Border forces that are
out there and the people who are
crossing because you can actually freeze
to death right I appreciate that you
bring that up the Canadian on the cast
bringing that up thank you very much
look Team Canada is important too it
hangs out there but not all Canada is
Justin Trudeau's Canada I have watched
with my own eyes in real time fenel
being tracked by United States
Department of military private
contractors from China I've actually
seen it on the computer screen being
tracked And yet when it gets to
Mexico somehow it makes it across it's
like some operation f infurious
situation like we know where it is we're
tracking it then it just backfires it's
a sincere desire to stop it but once it
arrives in Mexico then it breaks down
from there crazy the cartels are running
those some of those border towns I mean
the amount of fentanyl those millions of
pounds at one of those places I forget
what the what town it was maybe near
Tucson but it's it's apocalyptic how
much fentel is coming through and the
idea that China doesn't know about this
when they have like one of the most
extensive like uh surveillance states in
the world they're saying oh we don't
know where it's coming we have no idea
who's making this and also that's just a
fact no they're catching at the border
so much coming through I'm having a real
hard time deciding whether I'm more
afraid of what's happening in the Middle
East right now are we going to have
World War II or about what's going on at
the border I'm still struggling between
the two I think we should put the Border
first I mean that's my personal opinion
right like I can't say everything that's
going to happen abroad but I can say it
is crazy to me that we aren't all like
immediately score the Border it's crazy
to me that Texas is saying or the
federal government is saying Texas take
that razor wire out so people swim
across the Rio Grand rather than go
through a legal Port of Entry while
they're trying to illegally enter this
country like these are things that are
within our control and we're actively
saying but look over there look over
there should we get involved over there
why don't we shut our own door I mean
I've said this before a couple times on
the show we should lock our door before
we say by the way this neighborhood is
dangerous like if the world's a
dangerous place right now why aren't we
showing up resources at home but to
Tim's Point earlier it's because the
military-industrial complex wants to
have the war over there because they can
then play with all of their big toys
they can't play with their big toys well
why don't they suggest deploying troops
to the border right I mean maybe it
wouldn't give you the paycheck that it
would if you were engaged
internationally but at least then you
would still have some income coming
through not that you should be in
support of the military industrial
conflict but I'm just saying they could
make money off of anything if they make
it look like it's worth deploying our
troops they just don't but that our
troops should be at the border that's
exactly where they should be they
shouldn't be over there in Jordan in a
limited deployment of being Canon fodder
for the uh you know the the the lindsy
grahams and uh you know of the world
that's I'm AF I'm afraid you saying big
toys overseas is going to give some
people really bad ideas of using them on
the border at some point but they won't
because they don't care about the Border
you know like what are they going to do
to these people at some point or or
they're turning on us yeah these are
like our honorary citizens now like
these people that are coming across the
border are giv like thanksgiv in Chicago
they're G like Thanksgiving meals and
stuff and they're like you know just
random families and it's like don't ever
try to migrate here legally which I know
your family had experience my had
experience with this like anyone who has
had to do it you guys have to figure it
on your own but if you come illegally
we'll give you a support the Border in
Yuma watching the border patrol sit at
the at the wall waiting with luggage
tags and bottles of water and their van
to take the people to HQ where if they
have a number to someone in the states
and that person picks up they will fly
you there for free is is insane totally
insane stuff and watching these
individuals come across and you see the
pile of the wristbands you've seen those
and the different colors see that they
they are the cartel's product and that's
what those wristbands represent and they
and when they reach different transfer
stations they get a new colored
wristband on the way we'll continue to
let the cartel people treat humans like
products will promote human smuggling by
keeping our border open so that Joe
Biden can say well Trump is the one that
closed the border and I'm the one who
opened it and aren't I a better person
for that when actually you're
encouraging horrible atrocities to H to
happen to you know I'm sure there are
some very desperate people who think
this is the right path forward I think
there are also people who just know I
can make I can have an advantageous life
if I illegally cross into America this
whole system is crazy and yet we're
supposed to pretend that Democrats are
supporting something good by saying no
no border restrictions are somehow bad
that seems crazy it's another
overcompensation even though Obama was
the one I believe who had people in
cages they say it was Trump so he's got
to overco compensate for the Trump cage
uh but so by doing that he's just opened
everything up well humans can be uh
product here but they're going to be
Canon fodder over there and that's the
that's the conflict that we're looking
at do you feel like during your time
dabbling in journalism the conversation
around illegal immigration has changed
very much or do you feel like we're
we're just more Amplified on positions
that parties already held it's more
Amplified and and I'm you know I'm one
of those Libertarians who does not
believe in open borders because we live
in a dangerous world you know I I I I
have a utopian libertarian ideal I'm I
if I take the test I'm a full-on
Anarchist right except for one thing
that's not the world in which we live
right that's the world we want I wish we
could live in that world but we don't so
my attitude has not changed yeah and and
that I I had that attitude what about
other people who kind of share your
values do you feel like other
Libertarians have moved to more
closeboard position some have but you
know the idealistic of those who are you
know purist in some way right right
right thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net